Speaker 2: we have another
Speaker 1: one of these stories of what
Speaker 2: at this point.
I mean, I don't
Speaker 1: know if we just have to call this
finding out the hard way.
Another anti-vaccine
Speaker 2: Republican, this one
Speaker 1: in
Speaker 2: particular, was pushing
Speaker 1: the Big Lie that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 election, but it was stolen by
Joe Biden.
I mean, it's exhausting to even repeat it
at this point.
Speaker 2: A local Michigan Republican official,
Speaker 1: Republican official reports The
Daily Beast, who refused to certify Joe Biden's
presidential victory in his county.
And who very much opposed vaccines has died
of COVID 19.
This was 63 year old William Hartmann.
He we now found out.
Speaker 2: Died on November 30th
Speaker 1: in a hospital in Michigan.
He would regularly spread lies and conspiracy
theories about the election on, of course,
his Facebook page and a fellow Republican
on the Wayne County Board of Canvassers initially
Speaker 2: declined to certify
Speaker 1: the tallies of the 2020 presidential
election votes after they come in.
Speaker 2: And Hartmann agreed with that and
tried
Speaker 1: also to prevent their certification,
and ultimately they did certify the vote count.
Then they said, We're going to take back our
certification.
Some of you may remember, like we talked about
this in Michigan, where there was a certification
and then they wanted to take it back.
Speaker 2: But it was too late on and on and
on this same guy.
William Hartmann said on Facebook that vaccine
Speaker 1: passports
Speaker 2: resemble
Speaker 1: Nazi Germany's draconian laws,
and he has continued with this incredible
string of completely bonkers COVID vaccine
denial and conspiracy theories and other things.
And he ended up in the hospital with the virus,
and he has subsequently died.
We learned that he was in the ICU with pneumonia
and on and
Speaker 2: on and on.
So at this
Speaker 1: point, are these stories
Speaker 2: unique?
They are not.
Is this at
Speaker 1: the end of the day finding out
the hard way?
We knew what to do.
We knew how to do it.
The vaccine was free to him, and he didn't
get it now with any individual case, and this
is always the important thing.
You will have people who will come back and
say, But David, can you say for sure that
if this particular individual had been
Speaker 2: vaccinated, you would have survived?
And of course, not.
Nobody is saying that.
Speaker 1: What we do know is that being vaccinated
dramatically reduces the odds that you end
up
Speaker 2: very, very sick or dying
Speaker 1: and at a population level.
Not necessarily.
William Hartmann, but at the population level,
we know what there is to do.
And part of this, you know, I hesitate to
use this term, but there's a very specific
way in which it makes sense.
These unvaccinated COVID deaths, when
Speaker 2: these are just choices not
Speaker 1: to get vaccinated, often because
of false beliefs about the vaccine.
These are wasted that these are pointless
deaths.
And what I mean by that is if you didn't do
the simple thing, that would likely prevent
Speaker 2: you from dying.
Not guaranteed,
Speaker 1: but likely you didn't do it, then
it's very stupid to die in this way in the
sense
Speaker 2: that just getting a free
Speaker 1: vaccine might have kept you alive.
Now, of course, there are people who do all
of the things that are available.
Speaker 2: They follow
Speaker 1: various guidelines.
They get vaccinated.
And sadly, they still get sick and die.
Colin Powell is one of them.
That's a different situation.
And of course, because we know that that will
happen to some people.
Why would we want to add on to that
Speaker 2: by tempting fate, by saying I'm
not
Speaker 1: going to go and get vaccinated?
It makes no sense in that particular sense.
Speaker 2: It's a dumb death,
Speaker 1: and it doesn't mean that getting
COVID is feminine the way, Tucker said.
It just means if you've not done the
Speaker 2: basics, which are free
Speaker 1: to give yourself a better shot
at staying alive.
If you get this disease, then you're sort
of learning the hard way.
Now that the last thing and I've said this
before, I'll say it again.
This is not merely
Speaker 2: a self resolving
Speaker 1: problem we can look away from.
What I mean by that is, as we've said before,
if this is just as simple as only the unvaccinated
will die.
As a result of them not getting vaccinated,
we could look away and say it's sad, but at
the end of the day, it's your own funeral,
Speaker 2: but it's a
Speaker 1: contagious
Speaker 2: disease and we don't
Speaker 1: know how many people did William
Hartmann.
In fact, maybe some were too young to get
vaccinated.
Maybe some were vaccinated, but
Speaker 2: were very sick.
Speaker 1: So in getting COVID and dying,
how many other people might he have taken
down with them?
And of course, we don't know the answer, but
that's the reason why we can't simply look
away and say, Well, who cares if anyone gets
vaccinated?
I did, and I'm now protected, and it's as
simple as that.
It is a communicable disease, and the behavior
of these people affects others as well.
So tack another one onto the list.
Notable anti-vax Republican pushed vaccine
conspiracies
Speaker 2: pushed election
Speaker 1: conspiracies now dead of COVID.